[Music]
hi paxton we heard london's in total
lockdown we are all locked in the
psychological prison of burning
aloneness how's linda
she's somewhere in the house is there
some type of issue
we are fine
[Music]
not only is everything not okay nothing
is okay linda said she was planning to
end
our thing
[Music]
my life i'm going to get provisions we
need milk bread
how many houses have you got piss off
the nice people that i fired they were
fired because of me it's not about the
virus it's about who i
am and what i do for a living you fired
them well
thank you is that a glass of wine yes
yeah it is
we have a situation all the major
department stores are closing
they want everything over the next four
days we have a problem at harrods we
have four million dollars worth of
jewelry
someone's gonna have to pack the
valuables up i believe you are a man who
can be trusted yeah i
am no i can be trusted
it's gonna have to be someone that we
trust so that means inevitably it's
gonna be me
what are you taking out of harris a
diamond it's a new day
since lockdown i'm looking back at
myself like that was dead and this is
now
yeah the bastards who told me to fire
those people they're bad
you and i are good and good is better
than that you're talking about stealing
a diamond
three million pounds live wild or die
linda
and i'm feeling good
carrots is the most glamorous store in
the world
i know all the security guards i know
the security systems
i just need to get the gentleman's name
his name
edgar allen poe edgar allan poe wow
what can go wrong lock down one last
ride
i'll load the world in heaven oh my god
give us the sum of deception
please report to security
a month ago we'd be doing this not me
and i'm feeling good
[Music]
you